what do you think of dating apps really
want to go here of course I want to go
there I think that dating apps are a
perfect example of something which is
both convenient and enjoyable but not
good for you they have certainly opened
up more opportunities for people to meet
potential partners and yet we are in a
world with the highest rates of
uselessness amongst young people one in
three men between the ages of 18 and 30
hasn't had in the last year the only
half of men between the ages of 18 and
30 are looking for a relationship well
if the promises of easy access online
dating were so true how is it that we've
ended up with a world where people are
having less than ever that's uh
sexlessness has also increased for women
too there are more childless women at 30
than there are women with children
there's a study from Morgan Stanley that
says by 20 40 45 of 25 to 45 year old
women will be single and childless if
online dating was creating this perfect
facilitation for relationships to start
how are we ending up with all of these
outcomes